it is the vehicles coming in and out of
this building that tell their story an
ice-rink
converted into a morgue and Spain's
nightmare shows little sign of abating
today the Spanish cabinet met to agree
an even tougher lockdown the Prime
Minister was there his deputy absent
with coronavirus Spain at all levels is
struggling to cope it is true that as I
said before the number of people going
into intensive care units is still
increasing and there are many regions
operating at maximum capacity in many
other regions quickly getting closer to
the limit
a month ago Spain had suffered a total
of one death from this outbreak this
weekend it's lost more than 800 people
each day Italy and Spain are the two
worst hit countries in Europe look at
this graph the blue line shows how Italy
moved from a thousand deaths to a total
of 6,500 in just under two weeks but
Spain has made that progression in just
nine days I spoke to one doctor a cancer
specialist now treating victims of a
very different disease what is it like
yeah it's a very very difficult
situation at this moment because all our
lives are coronavirus life
just this morning I become from the
hospital is Sunday is not the normal
date will work half the deaths have come
in Madrid but the virus is spreading
more than a thousand people have now
died here in Catalonia in Barcelona
hospitals are being rapidly redesigned
here a patient has helped to make a call
home for anxious relatives the demand
from so many is so familiar now stay at
home I think that in a few days we will
be in it would be worst but I hope if
people
stay at home it could be better but it's
very important that that everyone must
know that they have to stay home
Spain is suffering and waiting to see
when this vicious virus will loosen its
grip there are small signs that a spread
of the corona virus is slowing here
there is hope but there is also fear
Adam Parsons Sky News